[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اهلا بكم الى النشره المفصله من العربيه
انا ميسون عزام احييكم وهذه الخامسه
مشاهدينا نبدا بالعناوين
يهددوا باحراق دبابات الغرب في اوكرانيا
وفنلندا تشترط موافقه برلين لارسال دبابات
اليوكارد
على خلفيات الاعدامات وزير الخارجيه
بريطانيا امام البرلمان للرد على اعدام
علي اكبره
الجمهوريون يزيدون الضغط على الرئيس
الامريكي ويطالبون بسجل زوار منزله بعد
فضيحه الوثائق المسربه
الجيش الصوماليه لانه مقتل 23 عنصرا من
تنظيم القاعده ويفرض سيطرته على مدينه
جلعت بوسط البلاد
اذا مشاهدينا سنبدا الخامسه من تطورات
الحرب الاوكرانيه توعد لكريملين باحراق
الدبابات التي وعدت بريطانيا بارسالها
لاوكرانيا
وبخصوص المبنى السكني المدمر في دنيبرو
تهمل كريم لان الدفاعات الجويه الاوكرانيه
بتدميره نفا الكرملين في هذا السياق ان
يكون قد قصف اي مبنى سكني في المدينه بيان
لكريم لان نفع كذلك وجود اي صراع بين
الدفاع الروسيه وقوات بادنر التي تقاتل في
سوليدار
على كل المزيد حول هذا البيان معنا من
موسكو مراسله العربيه كاتيا طعم اهلا بك
كاتيا اسمحي لي ان اتحدث بالتفصيل عن هذا
البيان هل فيه بالفعل اي جديد في ما يتعلق
بالاسلحه التي ترسل الى كليب ام ان التغير
فقط باللهجه ربما هناك اللهجه تصعيديه
اكثر
مرحبا ميسون حقيقه
المره الاولى التي يقوم بتهديد تهديد طبعا
الغرب في حال قام بتزويد بتزويد اوكرانيا
بالاسلحه التي يعتبر طبعا ان هذه العمليه
هي التي تطيل من عمليات او العمليه
العسكريه الروسيه في اوكرانيا هو لطالما
هدد في وقت سابق بان الاسلحه الغربيه في
اوكرانيه هي هدف ستكون هدفا للقوات
الروسيه لا ربما هناك طبعا همم قليل من 90
في هذه اللهجه اليوم كما قال همم المتحدث
الرسمي باسم الكربلائي في سكوف قال لان
هذه الدبابات التي انحصلت عليها اوكرانيا
لندن همم تشالنجر 2 سيتم حرقها وبالتالي
هو طبعا يشير الى ان الغرب او عدم وجود اي
نيه لدى الغرب لوقف عمليه التزويد
اوكرانيا وبالتالي همم لا تدفع اوكرانيا
العمليات همم التهدئه او المفا مع اجانب
الروسيه للطاعاتي مع الملف الاوكراني في
الخارج ولكن ماذا عن الداخل طبيعه
التحركات التي تؤخذ الان ان كان فيما
يتعلق بدعم الاقتصاد او حتى فيما يتعلق
بما يقال بانه عقاب للروس الذين غادروا
البلاد
بالفعل ميسون بعد ان غادر الالاف من
المواطنين الروس سواء عند بدايه العمليه
العسكريه الروسيه او عند اعلان عمليه
التعبئه التي شهدناها في العام السابق بعد
فرار الشباب الروسي كان هناك دعوات وسط
السياسيين وايضا ان هو في مجلس الدومه
اولا همم
الحصول او همم اخذ العقارات التي تعود
لهؤلاء المواطنين ومصادراتها من منهم همم
هذا من جانبه من جانب الاخر كان هناك
دعوات حتى للسحب الجنسيه من هؤلاء
المواطنين الذين فروا من البلاد طبعا
معتمدين انهم خونه همم
ويجب عدم السماح دخولها مره اخرى الى
روسيا ولكن الكرملين عاده واكد مره اخرى
ان هؤلاء المواطنين هم لا يزالوا طبعا
مواطنين رؤوس ويجب عدم اغلاق الابواب
امامهم للدخول الى روسيا لذلك هناك تفاوض
في همم في هناك تفوت في النبره بين
السياسيين والدعوات هذه وبالاخص من الذين
يؤيدون العمليات العسكريه الروسيه في
اوكرانيا بهذا الاطار هل يمكن الحديث عن
الانسان الانتخابات القادمه وهل يمكن
لبوتن ان يبقى او يغادر بهذه الفتره
الحساسه ماذا نتوقع
همم
اكد انه حتى الان الرئيس الروسي لم يتخذ
القرار فيما سيترشح سيترشح الى الانتخابات
الرئاسيه القادمه طبعا هو كما قال ان هذا
يعتمد على اشياء او افعال همم ما بدا به
الرئيس الروسي من مشاريع او من اشياء خلال
العوامل السابقه والتي يجب ان تنتهي
بالاول ومن بعدها
سوف يفكر رئيسي في ماذا سيترشح الى
الانتخابات الرئاسيه القادمه في روسيا في
العام القادم همم لذلك حتى الان لا نعلم
نيه الرئيس الروسيه اذا كان يحضر احد ان
ينوب عنه او سيكون مدينه في الانتخابات
الرئاسيه القادمه ميسون من موسكو مراسله
العربيه شكرا جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
تقدمت وزيره الدفاع الالمانيه
استقالتها رسميا الى المستشار الالمانيه
افادت وكاله رويترز وذلك قبل انعقاد مؤتمر
للنيترو مرتقب في المانيا حول
الازمه الاوكرانيات تاتي هذه الاستقاله
لوزيره الدفاع الالمانيه عقب سلسله من
الانتقادات لها على خلفيه حرب الروسيه
الاوكرانيه الى جانب تصريحات اثرت جدلا في
اوساط السياسه الالمانيه من جانبها قالت
الحكومه الالمانيه
للدفاع خلفان لها قريبا
عندكم عندكم
خلفيات هذه الاستقاله هل اتضحت الصوره ان
كانت بالفعل الاسباب الرئيسيه هي اخفاقات
ربما في تعاطيها مع ملف الحرب في اوكرانيا
او لا الموضوع شخصي وطالها شخصيا صراحه
اهلا بك يا ميسون يعني هو يمكن القول له
علاقه بالحرب باوكرانيا ولكن ليس
بالقرارات الرئيسيه التي تتخذ لان
القرارات الرئيسيه التي تصدر عن وزاره
الدفاع في ما يتعلق الحرف في اوكرانيا
يتخذها في النهايه المستشار الالماني
ولهذا ربما يعني صمدت في موقعها اكثر من
ما كان يجب ان تصمد لانه منذ ان تم
تعيينها قبل عام
والفضائح اذا ما اردنا القول تلاحقها اا
يعني كنا نعرف انه كان هناك فضيحه قبل
بضعه اشهر بانه ابنها استخدم طائره للقوات
الالمانيه الخاصه لكي ينتقل الى احدى
الجزر الالمانيه لاجازه ايضا يعني كان
هناك كلام لها في بدايه الحرب مع اوكراني
بانها ستقدم لي الجيش الاوكراني خمسه الاف
خدع عسكريه هذا تعرضها لانتقادات كبيره
ولكن ربما الشريط المصور الذي نشارته عشيه
ليله راس السنه همم
وزاره الدفاع او المستشارين لديها كانت
تقف في وسط مفرقعات ناريه وتتحدث عن انه
هناك حرب وسط اوروبا وانا فخوره ب همم
الاشخاص الجدد الذي تعرفت عليهم من دون ان
تشير الى روسيا يعني موقف الحكومه
الالمانيه من روسيا هي المعتدي والحرب في
اوكرانيا وما الى ذلك وبدات وكانها تتحدث
عن انجازات شخصيه فخوره بها لذلك هذه كانت
النقطه الاخيره التي بالفعل يعني همم قامت
المعارضه ضدها وحتى الاعلام كان يقول بانه
هذا صحيح للغايه ويظهر بالفعل انها ليست
على قدر المسؤوليه من البديل راغده بنعرف
هناك مجموعه اسماء يعني ولكن ليس واضحه
ابدا المستشار يتكتم حتى الان على من يريد
ان يكون البديل ولكن نعرف بانه هذا المنصب
يجب ان يكون لاحد من الحزب الاشتراك
الحاكم لانه هناك ثلاث احزاب مشاركه في
الحكومه وبحسب هذا الاتفاق هذه الحقيبه هي
للحزب الاشتراكي لذلك هذا يقلص عدد
الاسماء ولكن يجب ايضا ان يكون هذا الشخص
لديه خبره بالقوات العسكريه الخاصه كان
هناك حديث على انه يجب ان يكون سيده لانه
ايضا تشارلز كان تعهد بان تكون حكمت
مناصفه بين الرجال والنساء ولكن يبدو بانه
هذا لم يعد معيار الان وانه معيار الاساسي
هو سيكون الكفاءه والقدر على تنفيذ
القرارات التي اتخذتها المانيا في ما
يتعلق اعاده اصلاحها واستمرار تقديم
المساعدات هل لديه وقت كم يحتاج من الوقت
وبالمقبل طبيعه الاجراءات يمكن ان تتخذ
الان
هناك تعزل في الواقع لانه تحدثت في الخبر
قبل قليل ميسون على ان هناك اجتماع يوم
الجمعه دعت اليه واشنطن في قاعده
ترانشتاين العسكريه الامريكيه هنا في
المانيا من المفترض ان يشارك فيه وزراء
دفاع الدول الصديقه لاوكرانيا لبحث
المساعدات العسكريه حتى الان غير واضح من
سيمثل المانيا ولكن هذا اجتماع مهم جدا
ويريد المستشعر ان يتعجل بان يعني
يسمي وزير الدفاع جديد او وزير الدفاع
جديده قبل هذا الاجتماع ولكن ايضا يعني هو
متغيب عن برلين لانه سيشارك في مؤتمر
الدعوه في يوم الاربعاء لذلك ربما النافذه
التي لديه صغيره جدا همم ربما يوم بعد ظهر
الامس او اذا اراد ان ينتظر حتى يعود ولكن
هذا يعني بانه قد لا يحضر وزير الدفاع
اجتماع الاجتماع الذي سيحضر وزير الدفاع
الامريكي لوليد اصلا همم لذلك اللي هو مصر
بحسب ما يعني كانت تقول وسائل الاعلام
الالمانيه بان يكون حاضر المستشعر
الالماني حاضر عندما يقسم هذا الو ضيفه
جديده اليمين لذلك ننتظر ربما يوم غد يكون
عنك
هذا القسم قريب من برلين مراسله العربيه
راقدهم شكرا جزيلا لك
اكد وزير الدفاع الفنلندي مايكروسوفوله
اكد ان موقف بلاد من منح دبابات اليوبارد
لاوكرانيا يعتمد على موافقه المانيا وفي
هذا الاطار قال
بدلات مستشار المكتب الرئاسي الاوكراني ان
الرئيس بولو مارسنسكي يفكر في طلبي شحنه
من دبابات وبارد اثنين من رئيس الوزراء
الكنديه جاستن تودو واضاف المستشار
الرئاسي في مقابله صحفيه ان الكلمه القصر
في تسليم هذه الدبابات تعود الى المانيا
باعتبارها صاحبه التكنولوجيا
هذا ومع تصاعد وتيره الدعم العسكري الغربي
لاوكرانيا يبدو ان الحرب قد تتخذ منحن
جديده وربما نوويا للمره الاولى اعلنت
روسيا انتاج رؤوس نوويه للتربيد بوسيدون
لاستخدامه في غواصه بالجرود النوويه طبعا
نقلا عن مصدر دفاعي فان روسيا صنعت اولى
ذخائر البوسيدون وستسلمها
وتتسلمها الغواصه قريبا جدير بالذكر ان
التوربيد هذا ويسمى ايضا بسلاح نهايه
العالم كان قد اعلن عنه الرئيس الريسيفر
الدمير بوتين لاول مره عام 2018 في حقها
قال ان التوربيد هو النوع الجديد تماما من
الاسلحه النوويه يعمل في اقصى الاعماق
وباضعف سرعه اي غواصه او صاروخ اوسيدون
يمكن هو السفر لمسافه تصل الى 100 كيلو
متر في الساعه وقوه ثقل الحموله النوويه
الحراريه لديه قررها الخبراء ايضا
بالقنبله النوويه التي اسقطتها امريكا على
نكزاكي في نهايه الحرب العالميه الثانيه
طبعا هذه المعلومات دفعت مسؤولين امريكيين
للقلق من التربيض الخالق الذي قد يتسبب في
تسونامي نووي بحسب تعبيرهم فبحسب خبراء
عسكريين فان بالقدور وسفنا اخرى من سفنها
ومن فئاتها يمكنها اطلاق ما يصل الى ثنيه
10 من هذه التربه ذات نحو ساحل الولايات
المتحده
ادوات واجهه القياده العسكريه في اوكرانيا
اشكاليه من نوع اخر هي تدريب القوات على
اسلحه الغرب الجديده بدات القوات
الاوكرانيه تدريبات عسكريه موسعه تحت
اشراف الجيش الامريكي في المانيا ووفقا
للاسوشيات دريس سيشارك حوالي 500 جندي
اوكراني في برنامج الاسلحه المشتركه مع
امريكا وذلك خلال الاسابيع المقبله قبل
العوده الى اوكرانيا رئيس هيئه الاركان
المشتركه الجنرال مارك ميل قال ان الجنود
الاخرانيين يتدربون على اسلحه جديده ستكون
حاسمه في مسح القوات الاوكرانيه لاستعاده
الاراضي التي سيطرت عليها روسيا ياتي ذلك
في الوقت الذي تعهد فيه مسؤولنا امريكيون
بتزويد اوكرانيا ببطاريه الدفاع صاروخي
قال رئيس الوزراء السويدي اولف كريستي
وقال ان الوضع على صعيد المفاوضات مع
تركيا يصيروا على ما يرام تاتي التصريحات
بعد يومين من تاكيد الرئاسه التركيه انها
ليست في موقف يسمح لها بالموافقه على
انضمام السويد للنيترو مشيره الى ان على
السويد اتخاذ موقف اكثر وضوحا ضد من
تعتبرهم انقره ارهابي
في الخامسه ولكن بعد قليل
اليابان والهند تطلقاني اول مناورات
قتاليه جويه مشتركه لمواجهه النفوذ
العسكريه المتنامي للصين
اهلا بكم مجددا الى الخامسه ونكمل من
ايران حيث دعى المجلس التنسيقي للمنظمات
النقابيه للمعلمين الى انهاء وجود القوات
الامنيه بالمدارس الايرانيه والتي تعمل
على قمع الاحتجاجات الطلابيه المجلس اكد
في بيانه الوجود المستمر للافراد الذين
يرتدون ملابس مدنيه من مؤسسات مختلفه
وثقافيه في المدارس لغرض الدعايه وتبرير
لاجراءات النظام بحق الطلاب عمل غير
قانوني وانتهاك لخصوصيه المراكز التعليميه
[تصفيق]
هذا وقد اعلنت وزاره الخارجيه الالمانيه
استدعاء السفير الايراني وذلك للمره
الثانيه خلال اسبوع واحد طبعا بسبب عمليات
الاعدام التي تنفذها الايران واوضح متحدثا
باسم الخارجيه الالمانيه ان الخطوه جاءت
بسبب مخاوف برلين بشان سجل طهران في مجال
حقوق الانسان من جانبه قال المتحدث باسم
رئيس الوزراء البريطاني ريشي سناء قال ان
وزير الخارجيه جيمس بليبري سيتحدث امام
البرلمان بشان اعدام السلطات الايرانيه
للمواطن البريطانيه الايراني علي اكبر
وفي الاثناء تجمع الالاف من ابناء الجاليه
الايرانيه امام مبنى البرلمان الاوروبي في
مدينه ستراسبرج الفرنسيه هذه التظاهرات
تاتي للضغط على الحكومات الاوروبيه
والاتحاد الاوروبي بادراج الحرس الثوري
الايراني كمنظمه ارهابيه وزاره الخارجيه
الفرنسيه كانت قد قالت في وقت سابق انها
تعمل مع شركائها الاوروبيين على فرد
عقوبات جديده على ايران بسبب قمع
الاحتجاجات المستمره في ما لم تستبعد فكره
تصنيف الحرس الثوري كمنظمه ارهابيه وقد
وصفت المانيا هذه الخطوه المهمه والمنطقيه
السياسيه
على كل المشاهدين من امام مقر البرلمان
الاوروبي حيث التظاهرات في ستراسبرج ينضم
الينا مراسل العربيه فادي الدهوك اهلا بك
فادي انقل لنا الاجواء من عندك
[تصفيق]
مقر البرلمان الاوروبي كما تشاهدون هنا
عدد كبير من ابناء الجاليه الايرانيه
الذين قدموا من عدد كبير من العواصم
الاوروبيه يشارك في هذا التحرك متظاهرون
من حوالي 50 مدينه اوروبيه واطلق هذه
الدعوه للتظاهر اليوم النائب السويدي من
اصل ايراني علي رضا اخواني طبعا توقيت هذه
التظاهر التزامن مع اجتماع
للبرلمان الاوروبي سوف يبدا غدا والهدف من
هذا الاجتماع هو مناقشه فرض حزمه عقوبات
جديده على ايران لكن المتظاهرون هنا
يطالبون بالضغط اكثر همم اتخاذ قرار
اوروبي اكثر حزما تجاه ايران وهو ادراج
الحرس الثوري الايراني على قائمه المنظمات
الارهابيه همم لدول الاتحاد الاوروبي همم
اجتماع يوم غد للبرلمان الاوروبي سوف يرفع
خصوصياته الى همم اجتماع وزراء خارجيه دول
الاتحاد الاوروبي الذي سيعقد في الثالث
والعشرين من هذا الشهر طبعا هناك دعوات
كثيره لان همم تكون من بين هذه التوصيات
ان يدرج الحرس الثوري الايراني على لائحه
المنظمات الارهابيه بالطبعا نعلم ان هناك
عقوبات اوروبيه منذ سنوات حقيقه على
شخصيات من الحارس الدوري الايراني لكن
تاثير هذه العقوبات هو فردي ويطال فقط
الاشخاص الذين تمت همم معاقبتهم لكن ادراج
الحارس الدوري الايراني على لائحه
المنظمات الارهابيه كيان سوف يعاقد الامور
اكثر على ايران وعلى النظام الايراني لانه
سوف يجعل التعامل مع ايران
امرايه الصعوبه بالنسبه لعدد كبير من
الشركات في دول الاتحاد الاوروبي وايضا
للشخصيات التي قد يكون لها تواصل مع ايران
من هي الجهه التي
تخاطب الجمه الان
من يخاطب الجمهور الان هناك متحدثون عدد
كبير من المتحدثين هذه احدى المنظمات التي
تتحدث الى الجمهور لكن كان هناك ايضا عدد
من النواب الاوروبيين وايضا من النواب
الفرنسيين تحدثت قبل قليل مع النائبه همم
في البرلمان الاوروبي من فرنسا
وتقول او قالت لنا ان هناك حاجه لاتخاذ
قرار حاسم وضغط اكبر على النظام الايراني
[تصفيق]
في اشاره الى ما يحدث هناك والى الاعدامات
الاخيره في ايران التي طالت عددا من
الناشطين همم وهذه كانت الدعوات الرئيسيه
التي جمعت كلها اولها من عدد كبير من
عواصم الدول الاوروبيه للاحتجاج هنا امام
مقر البرلمان الاوروبي في استراليا
شكرا جزيلا لك
هذا واكد المتحدث باسم الاتحاد الاوروبي
بيتر ستانو اكد ان المفاوضات مع ايران
طبعا بشان الاتفاق النووي لا تسير في
الاتجاه الصحيح قال المسؤول الاوروبي ان
وزراء خارجيه الاتحاد يبحثون الاتفاق
النووي مع ايران الا ان القمع الذي تمارسه
ضد المحتجين ودعمها لروسي عسكريا هما
امران يوضع عفان تعقدات المحدثات
مشهد غريب ينتشر بواجهات محلات الازياء
وذلك في جميع انحاء العاصمه الافغانيه
كابول مشهد ربما يكون مخيفا للبعض
العارضات في متاجر الملابس النسائيه
رؤوسهن مغطى باكياس من القماش او ملفوفه
باكياس بلاستيكيه سوداء وذلك بامر من
سلطات طالبان الحاكمه دعونا متابع
[موسيقى]
اطلقت اليابان والهند اليوم اول تدريبات
عسكريه جويه مشتركه وذلك بالقرب من طوكيو
طبعا بهدف تعزيز روابتهما الامنيه
والدفاعيه بمواجهه نفوذ الصين المتنامه في
منطقه اسيا والمحيط الهادئ وفقا لوزاره
الدفاع اليابانيه من المقرر ان تستمر هذه
المناورات 11 يوم في قاعده هي كوري الجويه
شمال شرقي طوكيو وتضم طائرات مقاتله
يابانيه وهنديه
في الخامسه ولكن بعد قليل
مع تنامي المخاوف العالميه الصين تستعد
لمواجهه جديده من اصابات كورونا مع
احتفالاتها بالعام الجديد
اهلا بكم مجددا الى الخامسه دشنا مركز
الملك سلمان للاغاثه والاعمال الانسانيه
مشروع يعنى بدعم المشافي والنظام الصحي في
السودان وذلك من خلال تسليم عدد من اجهزه
التنفس الصناعي للمشافي في ولايه الخرطوم
طبعا في خطوه تاتي ضمن مرحله اولى من
المشروع الذي يتكون من 10 مراحل في اطار
الدعم الانساني للسودان
من جانبيه اكد سفير السعودي في السودان
علي بن حسن جعفر اكد ان الدعم الانساني
لمشروع النظام الصحي في السوداني ياتي من
الباب الاغاثه على ان تستمر هذه المبادرات
ما تما استدعت الحاجه لذلك متابعه
في اطار ما تقدمه حكومه خادم الحرمين
الشريفين من دعم الانساني في كافه
المجالات
الاغاثيه والانشطه الانسانيه اللي همم
الشعب السوداني
وتستمر هذه
المساعدات انطلاقا من الحوت التي
ننسق فيها مع الاجهزه السودانيه
بدوره ذكر وزير الصحه السودانيه المكلف
هيثم محمد انه الاجهزه الصحيه هذه تم
شرائها من السوق المحلي وهو الامر الذي
سيضمن الاستمراريه لمده تصل الى عشر سنوات
مما يؤكد نجاح هذه الاجهزه في المرحله
الاولى الى جانب طبعا الدعم السعودي
بتستقبل اكبر عدد من المرضى خاصه المرضى
الحالات الحرجه
انه الاجهزه تم شرائها من السوق المحل
واذا بيضمن التشغيل وبضمن ضمان همم
الاستمراريه والتدريب والاستعراض بضمان
لمده 10 سنوات همم يؤدي حقيقه لانه نجاحا
مشروع ومستقبل المشروع وبالتالي يمكننا
بعداك همم
تنفيذ بقيه المشروع في باقي المستشفيات
وباقي الولايات
وكما تم الاتفاق كذلك مع الاخ السفير انه
همم نحن همم عم مع مركز الملك سلمان نرتب
ل- اا المشاريع القادمه في خطه يتفق عليها
طرفين
نجحت السلطات التركيه اليوم في تعويب
سفينه شحن الجناحات في مضيق البوسفور
اثناء ابحارها من اوكرانيا الى ميناء
مرسين التركيه مما ادى الى تعليق حركه
المرور في المضيق لفتره مؤقته
نجحت السلطات التركيه في تعويم سفينه كانت
قد جرحت الى ساحل بيكوز في شمال مضيق
البوسفور سفينه الشحن التي ترفع على مباله
جناحات في منطقه في شمال مضيق البوسفور في
وقت مبكر يوم الاثنين بحسب السلطات
التركيه لم يكن هناك اي اضرار ماديه او
بشريه نتيجه جنوح السفينه التي تحمل 13
الف طن من البازلاء مركز التنسيق المشترك
في اسطنبول الذي يدير عمليات اتفاق الحبوب
الذي توسطت فيه الامم المتحده قال ان
السفينه كانت متوجهه من اوكرانيا الى
ميناء مرسيل التركي على البحر المتوسط
وكانت الدول المعنيه قررت العمل الماضي
تمديد اتفاق تصدير الحبوب الذي يهدف الى
تخفيف نقص الغذاء العالمي من خلال تسهيل
الصادرات اوكرانيا الزراعيه من موانئها
الجنوبيه على البحر الاسود لمده 120 يوما
لقنات العربيه والحدث زيدان زينجو اسطنبول
في ليبيا مشهدا بدور اللجنه العسكريه
المشتركه خمسه زائد خمسه التي تجتمع في
سيرت مؤكدا انها تعمل لاحلال السلام فيكيا
في السكيورتي وبروسيا
السلام في ليبيا
[موسيقى]
اللجنه العسكريه
القوات المسلحه
[موسيقى]
والمتابعه على كل ان اخر ما توصل اليه
اجتماع اللجنه العسكريه خمسه زائد خمسه
المنعقد في سيره معنى من هناك مراسل
العربيه محمد مسعود اهلا بك محمد مسعود مل
معلومات المتوفره لدينا
الاجتماع نبدا بهذا الخبر العاجل وصل منذ
لحظاته رانيا قبل خروجنا على الهواء الان
وفد امريكي رفيعه المستوى ما علمناه من
مصادرنا الخاصه لم يتم حتى الان الف
الصلاه
اليه بانه قد وصل بالفعل الى هذه القاعه
من خلفي الان وهي عضو في الكونغرس
الامريكي وصلت الى القاعه رفقتها وفد من
يعني وفد حكومي امريكي لا تزال هويه هذا
الوفد غير معلومه حتى هذه اللحظه الان
دخلوا الى القاعه لاجراء مشاورات مع
اللجنه العسكريه عبر هذه البوابه او عبر
هذا المدخل الان وتم بدا اجتماع مغلق مع
اعضاء اللجنه العسكريه بوفديها شرقا وغربا
طبيعه هذا الوفد او حتى جدول الاعمال الذي
بدا منذ قليل الان نتزال كلها تحيط بها
السريه الكامله ميسون ولكن الاجتماعي قد
انتهى قبل دقائق من الان ما بعد خروج سيد
عبد الله بتيلي في مؤتمر الصحفي اعلن من
خلاله عن دعم البعثه الام همم الامميه لكل
اعمال اللجنه العسكريه وطلب ايضا الحكومات
شرقا وغربا بالضروره الدعم اهمال اللجنه
العسكريه بعد الثناء على اعضائها وموقفهم
البطولي فيما حققوه من انجازات حتى هذه
اللحظه الان فيما يبدو وبالرغم من السريه
الكامله التي تحيط بهذه الجوله العاشره من
نوعها من اجتماعات اللجنه العسكريه ولكنه
من الواضح ميسوم بيننا قد بدانا نغوص في
التفاصيل وفي اعماق التفاصيل في النقاب
المتبقيه من اتفاق وقف اطلاق النار
الموقعه في جنيف عام 2020 وهذه النقاط
ابرزها التي لا تزال عالقه حتى الان هي
نقطه اخراج المرتزقه والعناصر الاجنبيه
والمقاتلين واتحدث السيد باتيل بشكل واضح
بانه قد بدا التواصل فعليا من اجل المضيق
قدما في انجاز واتمام هذه الخطوه بعد ما
كانت هذه خطوه تمثل عائق او عقب امام
اعضاء اللجنه العسكريه في ما فاته او فيما
مضى لاعتبارين او لسببين رئيسيين اولهما
حاله انقسام السياسي في البلاد وعمرو وعدم
وجود السلطه سياسيه موحده تدعم اعمال
اللجنه وايضا تباين الموقف الدولي بخصوص
المرتزقه والمقاتلين الاجانب محمد
تتحدث انه يبدو انه هناك دور الاممي فعال
تقديم دعم طبيعه هذا الدعم الذي يمكن ان
يقدم عندما يتحدث عن ما ذكرته من نقاط
بانها ستساعد بحل هذا الملف في ظل
المعوقات همم مال اليات المطروحه من قبل
الامم المتحده بهذا الاطار
بهذا الصدر لا يوجد يعني تصريح وواضح او
اليه واضحه حدثتها البعثه الاميه ولكن
يبدو بان السيد بتيلي بحسب حتى حديثه
اليوم يحاول ان يقوم بتقريب وجهات النظر
ما بين الدول الفاعله والمتدخله سلبا في
شان اللبيب بمحاوله يعني الحصول على رؤيا
موحده تدعم اعمال اللجنه العسكريه وهي
العقبه الاولى او السبب الرئيسي الاول
لعدم تنفيذ
الباقي على اعضاء اللجنه العسكريه
الوفد ومما يتكون الوفد الامريكي المجتمع
الان مراسل العربيه محمد مسعود شكرا جزيلا
لك
بعد العثور على المزيد من الوثائق السريه
في منزل الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن بيسعى
الجمهوريون الان لتوسيع دائره البحث
والتحقيق بطلب سجلات الزائرين لمقرات
الرئيس الخاصه من زار مقر الرئيس في والمن
تن خلال العامين الماضيين هذا ما يريدون
معرفته بل ذهب البعض كالجمهوريه
تكساس الى حد التساؤل عما اذا كان اي
مواطن غير امريكي كانت لديه فرصه زياره
بيت بايضا في وقت من الاوقات وكان قد تم
تخزين الوثائق في المنزل في منزل نائب
الرئيس السابق والرئيس الحالي لمده ست
سنوات على الاقل لكن اكثر ما صدم
المسؤولين الامريكيين هو مكان التخزين
والذي كان في الواقعاب سيارات الرئيس على
عكس ترامب الذي يواجه ايضا قضيه مماثله
عندما عثر مكتب التحقيقات الفيدراليه على
وثائق في منزله الصيفي وافقت اداره
البايضين على اطلاق سجلات الزوار الى
البيت الابيض لكنها ابقت على هويات اولئك
الذين زاروا بايد سريه في حين سافر الرئيس
اكثر من 50 مره منذ تولياه منصبه
اهلنا الجيش الصومالي انه تمكن من قتل
ثلاثه وعشرين ارهابيا مرتبطين بتنظيم
القاعده وذلك في عمليه
السفلى على بعد 100 كيلو متر جنوب العاصمه
مقديشو واعلن قياده الجيش عن مقتل شخص
واصابته ثلاثه اخرين في تفجير ارهابي وقع
صباح هذا اليوم بمنطقته هالجن التابعه
لمحافظه ايران كما اعلن الجيش الوطني
تحرير مدينه جلال التابعه لمحافظه
الارهابيه
رئيس الوزراء ريشه هناك عن مقترحات جديده
لتضييق على الاحتجاجات لتوسيع نطاق
المواقف التي تكون فيها الشرطه قادره على
التحرك لمنع حدوث اضطرابات خطيره ففي
السنوات الاخيره اغلقت الاحتجاجات اجزاء
من وسط لندن منعت حركه المرور على الطرق
السريعه الرئيسيه مما ادى الى دعوات
للشرطه للحصول على مزيد من السلطه لوقف
هذه الاضطرابات هذا واصدرت الحكومه تشريعا
لمعالجته هذه القضيه في العامه الماضي
لكنها تخطط للمدير قدما في مجموعه جديده
من القوانين تعرف باسم قانون النظام العام
[موسيقى]
المزيد معنا من لندن مراسله العربيه عروبه
عبد الحق اهلا بك عروب بدايه هل لدينا
تفاصيل اوفا حول هذه القوانين الجديده
مرحبا ميسون فقط للتوضيح يوجد هناك مشروعي
مشروعا للقرار واحد يعرف بالبدلك اوردر
بيل والاخر وستراكسبل البابليك اورجبيل
الذي تتكلمين عنه هو يعني مشروع قرار يتم
مناقشته في مجلس الاوردات وهو ضد الاعمال
التخريبيه او ضد المظاهرات التي قد تتسبب
باعمال تخريبيه وهناك مشروع قرار اخر ضد
الاضطرابات وهو مشروع قرار لم يمرر بعد في
مجلس العموم وهذا مشروع القرار من من شانه
يعطي صلاحيات اكثر للوزارات بان تعطي
اشعارات عمل
للموظفين وهذا يعني انهم من يعني يتوجب
عليهم الالتزام بالدوام الرسمي واذا لم
يتم همم الالتزام بهذه الاشعارات سيكون
هناك محاسبه من نوع ما فصلهم او اما يعني
همم التقليل او التخفيض من رواتبهم هذا
المشروع القرار طبعا هو همم يتم عاشت الان
في مجلس العموم بتوصيه طبعا من حكومه
سوناك اذا مرر هلا هذا المشروع القرار في
مجلس العموم الذي يعني هو فيه اغلبيه لحزب
المحافظين المعضله ستكون في مجلس الوردات
مجلس اللووردات عاده فيه معارضه اكثر ل
همم مثل هكذا همم مشاريع قوانين وبالتالي
يعني هو سيكون فاصل المحدد
المشروع على القرار هذا اما انا سيمرر او
لا وسننتظر حتى نعرف ولكن عروب الى اي حد
مثل هذه القرارات ان كان فيما يتعلق
بالنظام العام او حتى في ما يتعلق
بالاضطرابات يغضب الشارع من هذه الحكومه
طبعا يعني الريش سوناك عندما دعم مثل هكذا
مشروع قانون قال بان يعني الاحتجاج او
الاضرابات هي جزء من الديمقراطيه البلاد
هنا لكن قال بان هذه الديمقراطيه ليست بلا
يعني بلا ضوابط يجب ان يكون هناك نوع او
حد ادنى من ضبط الحياه وعدم عرقله شؤون
الناس بشكل عام ونحن نعلم بانه في بدايه
هذه الاضرابات كان هناك دعم كبير للمضربين
خاصه فيما يتعلق بالاضرابات السكك
الحديديه والممرضين والاسعاف هذا الدعم
تراجع همم تراجع شعبيه بالحقيقه في اخر
يعني احصاءات للرئي خاصه فيما يتعلق
باضراب السكك الحديديه لكن هناك ما زال
دعم همم اضرابات
وموظفي الاسعاف بشكل خفيف وهو الذي من
المتوقع ان يكون في اليومين القادمين في
ال 18 وال 19 من هذا الشهر سيكون هناك
اضراب للممرضين والثالث والعشرين هذا
الشهر اضراب لموظفي الاسعاف وبالت بقى ولا
همم فقط لاشير بان مشروع القرار هذا لن
يؤثر على اضرابات هذا الشهر من لندن
مراسله العربيه عروبه عبد الحق شكرا جزيلا
لك
بعد ان رفعت الصين القيود التي لا طالما
فرضتها بخصوص كورونا تزداد المخاوف من
تفشل خطير للفايروس في البلاد مع بدء حركه
تنقلات سكان السنويه الواسعه طبعا هذه
التنقلات تتزامن مع الاحتفالات بالسنه
الجديده وقد اصيب حوالي ملايين الاشخاص في
الصين بكرونا منذ الحادي عشر من يناير
الجاري بحسب دراسه صادره عن جامعه
في الواقع لم اعد الى المنزل منذ اكثر من
ثلاث سنوات هذا العام لدي ظرف عائلي وانا
مضطر للعوده الى المنزل باقرب وقت
الامر جيد جدا
اشعر بانني جدا
بالاجراءات الاخيره التي قامت بها الصين
المتمثله في نشرها معلومات عن وباء قفد
نايت للجمهورنا
شهاده منظمه الصحه العالميه بالصين لنشرها
معلومات عن الوباء في المؤتمرات الصحفيه
للاليه المشتركه للوقايه والسيطره التابعه
لمجلس الدوله كما لاحظت ان الحكومه
الصينيه تكثف جهودها لتوسيع العلاج
السريري وخدمه العنايه المركزه لجميع
الفئات الناس واتفق الجانبان على مواصله
تعزيز التبادلات الفنيه والتعاون بشان
الوقايه من المرض والسيطره عليه الى جانب
الحفاظ على الامن الصحي العالمي
اليوم تتجه الامطار نحو داب وسويسريه مع
عوده اجتماعات يناير للمنتدى الاقتصاد
العالمي بعد غيابها لعامين وقبيل انطلاق
فعاليات المنتدى كشف استطلاع لكبار
الاقتصاديين اجراها المنتدى الاقتصادي
العالمي ان الثلثي المشاركين يتوقعون ركود
الاقتصاد العالمي هذا العام وعلى صعيد
الشركات 90% من المشاركين في الاستطلاع ان
ضعف الطلب وارتفاع تكلفه الاقتراض ستضغط
على ربحيه الشركات هذا العام
المنتدى في دابوس ينعقد تحت عنوان التعاون
في عالم منقسم وسط مجموعه من العوامل التي
تفرض نفسها على اجنده هذا العام على راسها
التضخم شبح الركود ايضا وبالتاكيد اقتراب
الحرف في اوكرانيا من نهايه عامها الاول
دعونا متابعه
المنتدى الاقتصادي العالمي في مدينه دافوس
السويسريه يعود هذه السنه في نسختها
الشتويه لاول مره منذ الجائحه العام
الماضي اقيم في شهر مايو ما الذي يميز
دافوس هذا العام انا لا حبيب راح صلي
الضوء على خمسه امور اساسيه اولا عنوان
المنتدى التعاون في عالم منقسم كوفريشن
ماذا يعني ذلك يعني ان العالم منقسم بسبب
الازمات الصحيه والاقتصاديه والسياسيه
التي لحقت به مثل حرب اوكرانيا وكوفيت
وازمه غلاء المعيشه والتباطؤ الاقتصادي
كلها ازمات مترابطه وحلها يستدعي التعاون
بين القطاعين والخاص ثانيا الحضور الحضور
اقوى من اجتماعات مايو وهناك عدد قياسي من
الرؤساء التنفيذيين اكثر من 600 رئيس
تنفيذي الوجوه التي عادت الى دافوس هذا
العام رؤساء جيبي مورجان جولدن ساكس
بالعكس سون وغيره ثالثا المنتدى الذي
سيطرت عليه الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه في
اجتماعات مايو حارس هذا العام ان يعطي
ايضا اهميه لتداعيات هذه الحرب الرئيس
الاوكراني ذا لانسكي يشارك عبر الفيديو
وزوجته حضوريا اما المليارات الروس
فغائبين لسنه الثانيه على التوالي رابعا
الحضور الصيني جيد وعلى راسهم نائب رئيس
الحكومه ولكن اجراءات الحج الصحيه التي
كانت موضوعه وترقب راس السنه الصينيه في
الثانيه والعشرين من شهر يناير حتى من عدد
المشاركين خامسا واخيرا هناك قريه
افتراضيه فيلم يشارك فيها المسؤولين عبر
الافاتارز وهناك جناح لشركه ارامكو تعرض
فيه مشاريع من الطاقه المتجدده الهدف من
هذه القريه ايجاد حلول لبعض مشاكل البيئه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
الان الى اخبار الخامسه الرياضيه مع ديما
محمد الساحر
[موسيقى]
شكرا لك ميسون ومرحبا بكم مشاهدينا احرز
برشلونه كاس السوبر الاسباني بعد فوزه على
ريال مدريد بثلاثه اهداف لهدف على ملعب
الملك فهد في العاصمه السعوديه الرياض
تفاصيل المباراه في تقرير التالي
[موسيقى]
كرنفالون في استاد الملك فهد بالرياض
بحضور نحو سبعين الف متفرج احتشدوا لدعم
برشلونه وريال مدريد المدرب الايطالي
الفرنسي كريم بنزيما وجها لوجه مع
الكتالوني بوسكيت كله هذا على الاراضي
السعوديه
نهائي كاس السوبر الاسباني
برشلونه يكرر المحاوله وراسيه ليفاندوفسكي
تظل طريق المرمى
الفريق الكتالوني اكثر خطوره في المره
الاولى الدفاع يتصدق وفي الثانيه الخائن
يدافع عن الكتيبه البيضاء في النهايه
الكره الى خارج المستطيل الاخضر ريال
مدريد يرد بهذه المحاوله عن طريق مندي
الذي ارسل كره لكريم بنزيما والاخير لا
ينجح في الوصول الى المرمى
[تصفيق]
يتلاعبوا في الدفاعات المدريديه كان ذلك
قبل ان تهدر الكتيبه الكتلونيه فرصه
التقدم
برشلونه يستغلها الدفاعيه مدريديه لتصل
الكره الى كافه والاخير يسجل الهدف الاول
للفريق الكتلوني
بعدها بقليل ليفاندوفسكي يكشر عن انيابه
قبل ان يضاعف النتيجه
في الشوط الثاني ديمبلي كان قريبا من
اضافه الثالث لبرشلونه وكرتوا يتعلق في
التصدي هذه المره
[تصفيق]
والاخير
بجلوسه على دكه البدلاء بعدها بقليل
برشلونه يوصل زحفه نحو اللقب بتسجيل الهدف
الثالث عن طريق بدري
ريال مدريد يحاول تقليص النتيجه في اول
لقطه مقربه
محاوله جديده للريال واشتيجن يحافظوا على
نظافه الشباكه كان هذا قبل ان يقلص كريم
بنزيما الفارق بتسجيل هدف شرفي لريال
مدريد
هدف لم ينل من انتصار برشلونه الكاسح
وفوزه بكاس السوبر الاسباني
هدى زين الدين العربيه
وعاشت العاصمه السعوديه الرياض يوما
استثنائيا على واقع الكلاسيكو الاسباني
فهد الشهري رصد الاشواق
[موسيقى]
حياك الله الله يحييك يا هلا مرحبا
ان شاء الله اليوم برشلونه
جدا جدا جميله قسم بالله
ان شاء الله ان شاء الله المباراه راح
تكون من الطرفين باذن الله بعيد عن اجواء
انك انت مين بتشجع او لمين اي فريق تنتمي
الاجواء جميله بشكل عام المباراه
ريال مدريد برشلونه
المره هذه برشلونه يتفوق شويه
ريال مدريد يعني فاهمه حاجه
نهايه لعبتنا الى برشلونه
[موسيقى]
ضد برشلونه فريق اخر برشلونه عقده ريال
مدريد
العاصمه لشبونه تعادل بنفيكا مع سبورتينغ
بهدفين بمثلهما في الاسبوع السادس عشر من
الدوري البرتغالي في الدقيقه 27 افتتح
سبورتينغها تسجيل عن طريق الكسندرا الذي
سجل بالخطا في مرمى فريقه وفي الدقيقه 37
لاحراز الهدف الاول ومع انطلاق الشوط
الثاني استرداد سبورتينج التقدمه بهدف
انسان سجله من ضربه جزاء وعاد راموس في
الدقيقه 64 واحرز اهداف التعادل الثاني
وبهذه نتيجه محافظه بنيكك على صداره
الترتيب بفارق اربع نقاط امريكا الذي يليه
في الترتيب
وفي مباراه ثانيه فاز بورتو على فملكه
باربعه اهداف مقابله هدف واحد ضمن منافسات
الاسبوع السادس عشر من الدوري البرتغالي
في الدقيقه العاشره افتتح بورتو التسجيل
عن طريق كلينيو وفي الدقيقه الواحده
والعشرين عاد نفس اللاعب وعزز من تقدم
البوتو بهدف ذلك وقبل ثلاث دقائق من نهايه
الشوط الاول سجل اوتافي الهدف الثالث
لبورتو ومع بدايه الشوط الثاني اضافه مهدي
تارمي رابع الاهداف وحمل هدف امريكا او
الوحيد اسم روفنتي في الدقيقه ال 50 وبهذا
الفوز رفع بورتو رصيده الى 36 نقطه في
المركز الثالث وبفرق خمس نقاط
يلتقي المنتخب العماني مساء اليوم مع
نظيره البحريني في نصف نهائي كاس الخليج
المقامه حاليا في البصره العراقيه
المباراه ستجمع بطلي اخر نسختين من
البطوله بعدما حققت البحرين لقبها الاول
النسخه 2019 في قطر وقبلها فازت عمان بلقب
الثاني من ارض الكويت عام 2017 وكانت
مواجهه المنتخب الماضيه من كاس الخليج
انتهت بالتعادل البلاد فيما انتصرت عمان
بثلاثيه نظيفه في دور المجموعات من كاس
العربيه الاخيره
على باقي هذا الخبر نختم ونعود الان الى
ميسون
[موسيقى]
شكرا ديما كشفت الشرطه الايطاليه عن
اعتقال الهارب الاول في ايطاليا زعيم
المافيا
المدانرو وذلك بعد 30 عاما من الفرار حيث
تم القبض عليه في عياده خاصه في باليرمو
بجزيره صقليه
[موسيقى]
ومن اخبار المافيا الى الباكس اوفيس او
شباك التذاكر حيث حافظ فيلم افاتار على
صداره شباك التذاكر في امريكا للاسبوع
الخامس على التوالي الفيلم حقق ايرادات
تجاوزت 83 مليون دولار خلال عطله نهايه
الاسبوع وبذلك يرتفع اجمالي الايرادات
المحليه للفيلم الى 570 مليون دولار اضافه
الى ارادات على المستوى العالمي بلغت ما
يقرب من مليار ونصف
الملياردولار حتى هذه اللحظه
وبهذا نكون قد وصلنا الى نهايه الخامسه
شكرا لمتابعه مشاهدينا
[موسيقى]